firing FBI director James Comey sent
shockwaves around the world particularly
in Russia
CBS News correspondent Lizbeth Parma got
the rare chance to speak to Russian
President Vladimir Putin she got his
reaction yesterday at a hockey rink in
the resort city of Sochi Elizabeth
Palmer is there with the interview you
will see only on CBS this morning
Elizabeth good morning good morning we
were here in the southern Russian town
of Sochi where the last Winter Olympics
were held just as the Russian president
was preparing to play in an amateur
hockey tournament President Vladimir
Putin game face on came down the tunnel
and paused to make a political point
how will the firing of James Comey
affect US Russia relations with Estonia
fashion
well Union
the [ __ ] Cavalia the movie new methane
was wash WA poorest regions pathologist
mission tell me your question looks very
funny for me angry with abortion we have
nothing to do with that president from
these two trumpets we compete in various
modern Institute's is lacunae is acting
in accordance with his competence with
law in constitution we just ensure what
about us when we really like history
cigarettes leave Italy yes I am going to
play hockey with a hockey fan president
putin plays a good offensive game on the
ice and on the world stage and in this
case it's a charm offensive his comments
supporting Donald Trump were bolstered
in Washington by the appearance of
russia's Foreign Minister Sergei Lavrov
in the Oval Office with President Trump
also there the controversial Russian
ambassador Sergei kisi AK whose contacts
with the Trump team were being
investigated by the FBI under the now
fired James Comey back at the hockey
rink Kremlin spokesman Dmitry Peskov led
us to a back room to insist one more
time that Russia has been unfairly
blamed for meddling in US affairs this
cloud of suspicion around Russia and
Russia's intentions has just got thicker
how do you repair your reputation
well actually we are extremely sorry
about that some political figures in the
United States and some other countries
of the world they all of a sudden have
chosen a way of burning domestic
victories and domestic political points
by creating an external threat the
high-level diplomatic contact between
the Trump administration and the
Russians continues today Secretary of
State Tillerson is in Alaska for a
meeting about the Arctic with both the
Russian ambassador and the foreign
minister the Kremlin already this
morning has said it's cautiously
optimistic about the future of
us-russian relations in light of the
last 24 hours
Gail
was always interesting to see an
interview with Vladimir Putin because he
certainly doesn't give them to American
media how did you get this story we were
in Sochi to talk to the Kremlin
spokesman and he was here because his
boss was playing in this amateur hockey
tournament so we asked could we pose a
question to the president and after a
little bit of back-and-forth I said yes
and they physically positioned us where
I could intercept him as he was coming
out onto the ice but make no mistake
this is a very carefully thought-out the
Russians wanted to send a message a
friendly message to the United States
carefully thought-out indeed in fact
we've learned that it was President
Putin himself who asked President Trump
to invite Lavrov the Russian Foreign
Minister into the Oval Office for this
meeting that is now on the front pages
of all of the papers around the world
what do you think the goal was the
Russians hoped they would get along very
well with President Trump and it's all
gone very wrong they are now trying to
rebuild the relationship they very much
want to be seen to be partners with the
United States because that's good for
the reputation it would be very popular
here in Russia and the end game of
course is to get those sanctions lifted
as soon as possible
all right Elizabeth Palmer in Sochi
Russia thank you